what up guys Jason Silva here and
welcome to shots of awe on the test tube
network shots of awe is a series of
interviews building on my recent work my
shots of philosophical espresso shots of
awe offers a series of reflections on my
current thinking on the human condition
the ways in which we use technology to
transcend all previous limits the nature
of creativity the nature of what it
means to be alive the role of philosophy
in everyday life think of them as
inspired nuggets of techno rapture we're
gonna have new episodes every week so
make sure you subscribe as well as
follow the social links below and stay
tuned and check out test-tube comm
thanks guys
don't miss shots of all